Dragon Ball super is an amazing to be
doing really well right now and we all
know what success with the franchise
means it means hundreds of thousands of
comments spread across the web spouting
abuse at those whose opinions differ to
yours like in the case of all English
dub viewers how they should all just
kill themselves or at least that's the
only solution according to the comments
section apparently but admits this
wonder lineup comment splendor I stumble
across some comments that gave me an
idea
no not that these admittedly it's been a
while since I've taken a look at the
manga so I figured it might be fun to
see where I thought the manga surpassed
the anime with its choices in
storytelling so in order to pander to
the aggressive weaves of the internet
I've decided to list off the twelve
instances where I think Dragon Ball
super manga was better than its anime or
in the immortal words of slush dog 47
where is part two of every difference in
Dragon Ball super manga you lazy piece
of [ __ ]
Oh slush dog number twelve one thing you
might notice when reading the Dragon
Ball super manga is how they completely
fixed the resurrection head portion of
the story now I thought this was genius
personally they achieved this by taking
the existing portion of the resurrection
F story and proceeds to rip it out of
the manga throwing it into a fire that's
right it doesn't have resurrection F at
all it skips it entirely and gets
straight to the good stuff now I could
hear you're angry fingers pounding away
on those keyboards already actually
Toyota oak the creator of Dragon Ball
super manga made a limited release of
the resurrection F story for the movie
and you're right it hasn't been
retconned rated thing we see even
mentions it in chapter 5 you know
there's a but coming
but it's not part of the official
collection I know because I bought it
sweet
number 11 now judging from the last time
I brought this up people seem to be read
offensive about people ragging on during
the grey as a character so I think the
best way to deal with this subject is
with as much sensitivity and grace as
possible
during the cliche is a boring lazy shell
of a character that even after 20-plus
episodes with him has still not
established himself as anything other
than in other one of those forgettable
strong serious silent type antagonistic
oku people can complain about
cauliflower all they want but she at the
very least has an established
personality and character up until the
making of this video journey had a grand
total of who [ __ ] cares in the anime
am i exceeding and doing that angry weep
thing yet jokes aside in reality the use
of a character like this only works if
we see him do the things he supposedly
stands for action and experiences are
what makes a character relatable if all
Vegeta's character had was people
talking about all the awesome things he
did no one would care it's through
sharing those experiences with the
character that we'd grow to love them or
hate them Frieza cell majin buu beerus
Goku black these are all characters that
were interesting the second we saw them
the moment Frieza
opened his mouth or killed those
namekians you knew what you were dealing
with and you couldn't wait until goku
and the guys hustled with them yeah I
used the word tossing what of it
but Cleo taro didn't make the same
mistake instead the very first time we
see jeering in the manga is him coming
to the rescue in chapter 30 he shows his
dedication to universe 11 in this scene
by refusing to come to the tournament of
power because it would leave universe 11
vulnerable he eventually agrees to join
the team but on the condition that if
universe 11 is in danger at any point he
will leave to help them these are
instances that help the audience like or
relate to the character jiren number 10
now truth be told I didn't have a
problem with the exhibition matches
between universe 7 and universe 9 in the
anime I actually thought it was pretty
fun and oh look we get some majin buu
action too however I think we got
something more juicy in the manga
instead of an exhibition competition
between universe 7 and universe 9 pulls
straight from chapters 28 and 29 is a
showdown between
all the gods of destruction from the 12
universes however while amazing this is
short-lived as Zeno can't see or enjoy
the fight because it is too loud and
intense the manga then uses this as an
opportunity to establish the rules that
will eventually make up the term into
power like no gods of destruction
allowed and no flying but that's not
where it ends No this scene has one
final difference in the anime topples
first confrontation with Goku leads
viewers to believe that if Goku was to
go all-out
he would destroy topo however in the
manga topo actually wins the
confrontation showing the viewer that a
good strategy means more than power an
important concept to get over for this
arc number 9 this one's short but it's a
goodie
remember when Goku and Vegeta went into
the time chamber for 3 years in
preparation for the universe 6
tournament well I think the manga did it
better this scene from chapter 7 pretty
much hits all the same story points as
the anime except for one big moment that
honestly gave me goosebumps right where
the anime cuts off the amount of
continues for a little while longer
Goku states that they do not need to
worry about destroying things in here
and that is time to fight just like the
good old days and with that they assume
poses very reminiscent of another very
iconic scene only this time as Super
Saiyan blue it's a really cool nod to
Dragon Ball Z that only serve to enhance
that moment for me number 8 the
introductory chapter to the universe
survival portion of the manga chapter 27
has a host of differences but the best
alteration I found was a reintroduction
to the Prince of all Saiyans Vegeta
instead of being on earth waiting for
his babies to be born we pick up with
him training with Wiese as he is
observed by both beerus and the oracle
fish the fish tells beerus both Vegeta
and Goku would be his strongest rivals
leading beerus to challenge vegeta to a
fight reading this for the first time I
wasn't expecting it at all in fact when
they got ready to fight I was convinced
something random what happens so that
the fight wouldn't happen but thank
Christ on a bike nothing did because
what followed was awesome the scene
helps establish the mastery of Super
Saiyan blue a state similar to full
powered Super Saiyan like when Goku and
Gohan exited the chamber during the cell
saga this state is so far only
recognized in the manga however as I've
stated already the fight was awesome
climax scene with Vegeta landing his
first good punch on beerus which
naturally gives cause for beerus to
start taking things seriously i
especially love this because it's a
great indicator of where Vegeta and Goku
are in relation to beerus strength wise
there's actual progression happening
that we can see number 7 Dragon Ball
supers manga adaptation was very
consistent with its use of Super Saiyan
God
it seemed throughout the story's
beginning as well as chapters 13 and 22
this my friends is called consistency
this is important as it demonstrates to
us the consumer that
Super Saiyan God or the red-haired form
is just as viable an option as Super
Saiyan or Super Saiyan blue which
feature more prominently now instead of
consistency the anime decided to adopt
well I can only assume is the oh crap we
haven't used this form in ages better
start using it now approach I assumed
this because the anime decided not to
use it for 91 episodes for some reason
in the anime they only pulled it out for
the first act and the tournament of
power arc it was thought for a long time
that the red Super Saiyan God form could
only be attained through ritual and that
the manga was doing its own weird thing
turns out the anime was doing a weird
thing number 6
trunks stalling as Goku and Vegeta
prepare in the past is handled much
better and he doesn't get any random
powerup like Super Saiyan rage which
again happens without explanation or
context of scale in the manga he was
just happy that he was able to help Goku
and Vegeta get away he does this by
blindsiding black - not by overpowering
him with his father and Goku having
escaped he was ready to meet death but
out of nowhere go ah sue and Supreme Kai
appear and rescue him this is much more
cohesive storytelling instead of
suddenly getting a monstrous undeserved
powerup or trying to shoot Goku black
with a big bullet they get transported
to that timelines world at the Kai's
instead to wait for Goku and Vegeta's
return and this ladies and gentlemen is
what making sense looks like number 5 in
the Dragon Ball super manga the Supreme
Kai is a much more active and better
character in chapter 16 through
flashbacks it's demonstrated that he
sacrificed himself in the Future Trunks
his timeline to prevent the release of
majin buu in chapter 21 he demonstrates
his initiative and selflessness again
devising his own plan to aid in the
effort with Goku black and Zuma soo
after finding out that their next trip
will be their last opportunity to save
that timeline and finally in chapter 22
he even tries to avenge kawasu
considering the power difference between
him and Goku black he is one courageous
fellow in the manga in the anime he is
very much a forgettable side character
being more of a nuisance during the
Future Trunks arc than anything number 4
this one I think needed to be in the
anime but it wasn't for whatever reason
the mangas interpretation of Goku vs.
hit was great in my opinion but that's
not why this is on this list no it's on
my list for two pieces of information
that came during the fight the first
made Vegeta look less like Goku is less
and more is equal while the second maid
cook whose fights with hits more
airtight within the show's established
logic but let's look at specifics
firstly we have what I feel is the most
important inclusion Lisa's explanation
for why Vegeta wasn't as strong as Goku
when he fought hit in one panel he
explains that Super Saiyan blue has an
ignition that drains tons of stamina
going on to add that Vegeta was
one-tenth his full power when fighting
him
this doesn't make Goku any less awesome
and only serves to make Vegeta less
terrible in comparison I have no idea
why this wasn't part of that scene
initially the second piece of
information came after Goku had
surpassed hits time-skip Wiese again
explains that because goku is now at a
higher level of power to hit the
time-skip
is it effective the anime on the other
hand just has Goku powering through time
which on its own makes no sense number
three in chapter 19 instead of having
Goku go with beerus and we stew
investigate and confronts the masu like
they did in the anime the manga opts for
Goku and Vegeta to book it to the Future
to battle black instead thinking that he
black was acting alone what I love about
this chapter is its covering of two
stories taking place at the same time
with plots converging into one at the
end the two scenes in question are
beerus is confrontation of zuma suit and
the other being Vegeta and Goku is
confrontation or battle with black in
the future in the present supreme kai is
given a mission by beerus before he goes
to universe 10 looking for some acid
while this is happening in the future
vegeta begins his fight with black as
Goku watches back in the present beerus
describes what he suspects a massive
beam to which the masu tries to defend
himself supreme kai however puts it down
for unzoom Ash's defenses returning from
his mission revealing that he has gone
to the Masters future to see what he was
planning
giving Just Cause for beerus to unleash
his AK ions Amasa while this transpires
the battle continues with goku black and
vegeta in the future as vegeta launches
his final flash to finish goku black he
is saved by an unknown entity it's then
Torterra decides to switch us back over
to supreme Kai's scene as he explains
that it was worse than he had thought
black wasn't working alone
the manga immediately then switched back
to reveal that it was indeed there's a
masu from the future he went to visit
the sames imasu who saved goku black
the final flash it's difficult to
effectively describe but trust me these
two scenes are interwoven perfectly in
chapter 19 number 2 again looking at
chapter 19 because it's awesome I want
to draw attention to Vegeta's first
fight with Goku black comparing it with
the animes version these two iterations
while ending in the same place couldn't
be more different
and yes the mangas version is much
better first off it's explained that
Goku black is not able to fully utilize
Goku's powers leading to black
struggling in a Super Saiyan form
against a formidable Super Saiyan blue
Vegeta black later attained Super Saiyan
rose' and thanks to this slow burn from
Toro taro there is a much better
understanding of how strong each
individual character is compared to each
other
Tsubasa even explains that when a divine
being surpasses Super Saiyan God instead
of a blue aura it turns pink in the
anime this is vaguely explained away in
a sentence
leaving the viewers scratching their
heads the manga does a fantastic job
turning a confusing story into a
straightforward one that follows a clear
and consistent logic it even explains
why trunks has managed to stay alive all
this time because Goku black willed it
to be that way he wanted to use trunks
to unlock more of Goku's energy and
power I love this manga number wood from
chapter 22 to 26 the story derails into
something that is very much unique to
the mangas iteration it's filled with
some truly fantastic and welcomed
additions to the story but my favorite
comes in a short dialogue between Vegeta
and trunks on page 29 of chapter 23
right after Vegeta refuses to fuse with
Goku Toriyama has admitted in the past
to not being too comfortable writing
relationships and romances between
characters which I believe is a
contributing factor behind why this
scene in particular stands out so
prominently to me trunks talking to
Vegeta goes on to say I can't allow you
to sacrifice yourself for this world
father at the very least not for
Mother's sake did you say Booma is dead
yes you died here early on and mother
went through a really hard time raising
me on her own the very first time that I
had travelled to the past and had met
you after I came back she would often
ask me about how you were and how you
looked in truth if black hadn't killed
mom she had planned to travel back to
the past together with me this recent
time to me it always seemed like perhaps
mom cared even more but ganked
meet you in the past then she did
escaping from black bulla I don't want
to make mom go through anything else so
we can't allow you to die here when mom
in the past is waiting for you to come
home to her this is a fantastically
tender scene from the manga and stands
out amidst all the other fanfare to me
but in short this manga is fantastic
which is why I encourage anyone who
hasn't purchased a copy of it to do so
soon it's a perfect Christmas present
this manga needs to be supported thank
you guys for watching this episode if
you guys would like to see more episodes
like this or more dragonball content
please feel free to subscribe as always
Regan's and comments are very much
appreciated and i will see you guys next
week thank you so much for watching